o estudo bem gente boa tarde bom vamos
já comeu né mais animadinha não tá tão
calor lá fora viu sem sair agora o
problema está mais sossegado
vou falar sobre a conexão do rádio no
rádio é o meio que conecta gente como é
que tá muito né falar só ligar o rádio
lá colocar aquela introdução zinha lá
pra vocês
esses lembra disso alguém lembra que o
barulho e se muito antigo na chegar e
tentavam chegar a nada
às vezes chegava e chega uma coisa boa a
ser esse exemplo que vai chegar água
chegou muito bom agora essas companhias
do tipo uma corta essa beleza e você
quer que se esperava quando você
sintonizáveis quando você mexer no daia
ou não é que as pessoas não sabe o nome
daquele da eu né
hoje é digital nessa clínica lá é a
porcaria esse cara chato só tá essa
porcaria muda aqui é muito mais fácil né
o que a gente esperava esperava buscar
uma rádio que a gente ouve se que fosse
legal de um lugar que a gente tivesse
que tivesse alguma rádio interessante
uma música bacana
muitas vezes a gente buscava não a gente
busca ainda uma notícia importante você
quer ficar por dentro das coisas que
acontecem
você até muita gente hoje em dia a gente
tem muitas é rádios religiosas
às vezes a pessoa busca ouvir algumas
palavras de fé enfim é o que a pessoa
busca ouvir por exemplo notícias por
exemplo
o programa de notícias isna você
obrigado pela sua audiência você
acompanha as notícias do jornal da manhã
da jovem pan as do brasil 21 graus aqui
no alto da avenida paulista mesa já é
maravilha isso é sensacional favor legal
para ficar antenado o saber tudo que
acontece no mundo e tal se cria o
programa musical programa musical um
belo programa chique o que eu fazia
começa agora planeta dj jovem pan o
melhor jovem para gente jovem com amor
fala 'meu chegar em todo brasil é só o
balanço é mais um planeta de dinheiro
resultante da nossa espécie e por aí
essa opção acelerada que todo mundo
conhece fm que eu sempre fiz é pelo
menos a coisa que eu mais fiz na minha
vida é uma opção de fm ea gente sempre é
esperava alguma coisa o rádio sempre
traz alguma coisa interessante pra gente
nem sempre muitas coisas interessantes
mas o rádio é aquele aparelhinho aquela
aquele aparelho de comunicação que desde
muitos anos mostra talvez através de
ondas eletromagnéticas música notícia
informações fé e por aí vai traz tudo
isso pra gente é talvez um meio que mais
conecte a gente com o mundo ou talvez
tenha sido o primeiro meio que conector
ser humano de verdade até porque nós
seres humanos em homens e mulheres
nós talvez sejamos extremamente é
conectado a gente precisa se conectar
por falha de conexão atual a gente hoje
em dia você tá ligado em redes sociais e
internet você tem aparelho de celular
smartphone você tem o tablet você tem um
celular o o computador você tem sei lá
mil traquinas pra poder meio coisa
traquitana para poder fazer mexer na
internet saber o que está acontecendo no
mundo perfeito mas eu tô falando de uma
conexão totalmente diferente que essa
conexão que o rádio traz é conexão pela
emoção porque já percebeu que o rádio
emocional muito você ouvir o rádio é
claro que às vezes não tão positivamente
às vezes você ouve alguma coisa
mas isso é muito ruim isso não é legal
mas ao mesmo tempo ele também mexe com
as suas emoções ele mexe com que você
sente
quer dizer no geral rádio de trás mais
coisas boas do que coisas ruins como
desconectando você falar em coisa ruim
um trecho de uma coisa ruim que o rádio
traz funk que já tira tira gosto
particularmente eu gosto mas também eu
não sou contra quem gosta mas enfim o
funk vem e tudo que vem do rádio a gente
sabe mas também você pode ouvir coisas
que te levem a determinados momentos que
tragam imaginário aquela coisa imagina
já percebeu que o rádio é uma coisa
assim
a imagem na televisão é fantástica hoje
em dia a gente tem tv 4k tem hd tem sei
lá mais o quê
e tudo você vê você vê imagens você vê a
rugas e fala olha só como boris casoy tá
veio nessa hora imagem do boris casoy na
tv
nossa na rede tv ele está mais velho que
ele estava na bandeirantes fala eo boné
depois separou da fatma meu deus o
envelhecer os 10 anos em um cabelo
branco do boné gente se pega muito nesse
detalhe no rádio você não tem muito isso
o senhor quanto quem aqui já me parou e
ficou ouvindo a voz de alguém a voz de
um locutor uma banda nova um artista
novo e falou
será que esse cara né você está
trabalhando imaginário você está
conectando com sucesso
se conectando lá dentro do teu cérebro
para buscar será que o que ele quer
ficar feio bonito magro alto baixo
esse cara é desse jeito mesmo ou aquela
locutora
será que ela é parece ser lages e lindin
será que ela é maravilhosa ou será que
ela estranha ela parece minha mãe é uma
ninguém merece mas enfim
e você fica assim sem você perceber com
o trabalho imaginário como vai trabalhar
o imaginário da gente
por exemplo você ouvir uma notícia se
alguma notícia no rádio é com essa
premissa semana
se houve aquela notícia o ex deputado
eduardo cunha foi preso em brasília ao
nos arredores da sua casa na asa sul da
cidade
the federal vai falar você começa a
imaginar o eduardo cunha todo mundo a
maioria conhece assim imagina aquele
cara aquele barrigão arredores da casa é
que ao redor da casa será o cara também
uma caminhada em volta da casa dele você
começa a imaginar coisas correrem como
se imaginar coisas na asa sul de
brasília porque ela estava no avião na
sua relação começa a delirar
isso é um rádio ele começa a trabalhar o
seu imaginário
é aquela coisa de fora pra dentro de
dentro pra dentro você mesmo você começa
a imaginar se você ouvir o locutor hoje
tem a oportunidade de conhecer o cara
você vai no site da rádio tem lá cara do
cara você se decepciona só que coisa
hein cara feio a gente tem uma
brincadeira gente fala que o radialista
ele é bom para o rádio se ele fosse bom
para tv e seria bonito tão normalmente o
radialista é feio né
é uma máxima e se pode ter certeza e
essa história a gente vai trabalhando
imaginários e quantas vezes alguma
música me trouxe uma emoção do passado
se ouve uma música
temos uma música italiana muito bonita
se todos conhecem os mais velhos com
certeza o único lei do rei gourmet
[Música]
baroti monstro é sensacional
o pavarotti você prós e conheço agora
você sabe quem é a figura do pavarotti
quando você ouve uma música 10 primeiro
que traz muitas vezes para algumas
pessoas e emoções e traz sensações puxa
que legal uma vez que eu ouvi essa
música tá uma cantina italiana vê os
caras cantando na mesa lá mil coisas
podem acontecer e você imagina aquele
sei lá um palco o pavarotti na frente
àquele coral espetacular aquela
orquestra o maestro muito louco tá quase
rebolando aquela coisa toda será imagina
se não trabalha dentro da sua cabeça
quando você ouve essa esse tipo de
música ou seja qualquer tipo de música
seja a música que for você trabalha essa
conexão da emoção dentro da sua cabeça e
você fica trabalhando isso puxa que
legal
então o que concluo com isso que eu
passo para vocês um rádio é um meio de
conexão mais antigo que existe porque
quando o marconi inventou o rádio aí nós
estamos falando de 1899 o marcou e criou
rádio falou assim eu vou transmitir a
idéia de ler o seguinte bom
ele estava na itália sossegada inventar
um negócio aqui tal desempenho chamada
de rádio transmitir lá por norte da
frança que é gostoso clima bom dava
tomar um vinho eo transmitem com um
amigo meu me mandou a carta com o amigo
dele lá na grã bretanha falou comigo de
lyon seguinte fazer uma transmissão aí
vou te mandar um aparelho demorou três
meses para chegar o aparelho atravessar
o canal da mancha chegou aparelho e fez
a primeira transmissão em rádio e
transmitiu música e ele falou algumas
coisas no microfone improvisado e acabou
falecendo fazendo essa primeira
transmissão então é a primeira
transmissão do rádio que se tem é
notícia
1899 o radiante havia tentado isso 1830
40 50 mas só em 98 e 99
conseguiu-o marconi fazer isso ea idéia
de uma câmera simplesmente transmitir
alguma coisa passar alguma coisa música
informação notícias e o que quer que
seja mas ele jamais poderia imaginar que
o rádio não seria só isso que o rádio
seria um transmissor de emoções
volto a falar a conexão pela emoção né
quantas vezes seja nos pegou ficou muito
p da vida com uma informação alguma
coisa que você ouve se o apoio mas isso
não pode acontecer isso
o rádio ou quantas vezes você ouviu
alguma coisa que mexeu falou político
ilegal
muitos até choraram já com alguma coisa
até com alguma música que lembrou uma
coisa do passado
ou te fez chorar de raiva com uma e
desgraçado que acabou com sua vida
daquela desgraçada adorava essa música
nunca mais ouvi isso mas mexe com a
emoção sempre mexe com a emoção que o
que é mais engraçado você fica
trabalhando se imaginar quando você ouve
situações que acontece no rádio
uma situação que aconteceu que é mais ou
menos assim um programa de rádio fala
que estamos a rádio tex o carro locutor
fala rádio tex você liga a partir de
agora participa que comigo tudo bem com
você gostasse e só ligar para o telefone
3333 33 já tenho em sua linha lo
alan que está falando zezinho zé senhor
simpatia por onde a gente se interessa
retorno banheiro no banheiro é que
bairro que o bairro não é aqui não sei
que não é da estrada aqui é um lugar que
bela está certo que zezinho aqui nosso
pedido musical zezinho o que você está
fazendo
estou falando com você o bloco também
está usando o brasil nós é que falou
comigo mas beleza perde sua música
quisessem vamos direto ao assunto pede a
sua música aí eu queria ver a música do
rei música do rei presley por favor
com a bola rolando
[Música]
nadson pela cabeça mas não sabemos nem
mel nem no reino há a desculpa é do rei
roberto carlos aí sim em o rei e eu
estamos não é besta locutor como idiota
da emergência mas morreu no reino
agora sem desculpa rei do pop michael
jackson
[Música]
essa narrativa na coxa que não é correto
não não é mais o jogo já que a mulher é
bobô é só para aí então morrer a rainha
a rainha do pop madonna a abandona
como saber se ela não é rei e americano
sim mas não a dona toda vez que eu falei
sul americana mas só não ser o roberto
carlos mas que requer rav4 excluindo
essa aí toca a essa aqui então toda a
música do rei foram blogs fotos ap
e assim vai acontecer isso não é mentira
não acontece a gente a música do rei
imagina hair
eu lembro que alguns talvez não lembrar
de alguns locutores que fazem o programa
de de tradução 66 lembra disso a música
e uma música que particularmente houve
uma vez eu quase caí para trás
aí o cara o iess 100 e é sem ficar só
esperando o ias 100 e é sim e assim até
houve uma vez o frank sinatra ella hoje
vamos traduzir nova york nova york a
traduzir não vai acabar com new york new
york começou tanta estates prédio em um
de mills começam a espalhar as notícias
ano livre
estou indo embora hoje eu antes ia para
20 mil eu quero fazer parte disso nova
york e nova york
o cara interpretava mais que o frank
sinatra e tem um nome é sérgio boca um
cara que grupo até hoje ele faz isso a
tradução mas é legal é legal que neste
dia com as pessoas mexia porque algumas
letras têm a ver o seu ou violeta sem
ouvir o inglês não é todo mundo que
entende se fala tanto mais que legal
sensacional muito legal muito bacana
enfim ea coisa vai
isso é muito legal essa isso é moça você
está do outro lado se houver um diálogo
de seu uma tradução 10 e morre de rir ou
se emociona então ele mexe com você
o rádio méxico imaginário méxico a sua
emoção méxico as duas sensações
o que é o mais legal né a gente costuma
dizer que o rádio é por ter essa
facilidade em conectar o rádio é o meio
de conexão mais perfeito porque
você consegue dirigir mandar o whatsapp
quem consegue consegue né
não pode né meu pai dirige mas não sabe
quantas vezes tem que tomar usina
laginha né
você consegue está no banheiro tomando
banho e mandava e postar fotos instagram
da greve lamba xampu novo pra mim não é
o caso
shampoo novo ea gente não consegue
você consegue ver seus e mails correndo
na esteira ou a beleza também sobre os
meios 75 dias ele toca e assim vai jogar
videogame no trabalho um monte de gente
joga né não pode você pode fazer tudo
isso ouvindo o rádio não pode você pode
tomar banho no rádio
você pode mandar o whatsapp ouvindo
rádio você pode ver seus e mails ouvi no
rádio se pode até fazer um trabalho
ouvindo rádio
então rádio que fica conectado o tempo
todo sejam com coisas boas coisas aí vai
do gosto de cada um cada um tem seu
gosto falaram isso pra mim é melhor ser
um erro normal enfim o rádio por isso
mesmo a chamar de highlander
quem lembra do highlander é highlander
do filme highlander o guerreiro imortal
que a música do queen belíssimo a subir
em setembro essa música num
[Música]
essa música é do filme highlander é
highlander a história o christophe
lambert era um ator que interpretava o
maksoud é um escocês um guerreiro que
aprendia ele era imortal ele morrer
nunca tomava tiro e uma facada tomar um
tiro porrada e bomba beijo no ombro e
não morria porém tinham os nove aviões
que óssea de serpa cabeça mata arrancar
a cabeça para ficar com o carro morre
então era a luta entre o irã depois que
o rádio highlander porque quando surgiu
o disco vinil os cara o rádio acabou não
acabou
quando a televisão surgiu para matar o
rádio cabo rádio rádio não morreu
quando surgiu cb quem lembrar o quanto
tempo o rádio acabou não acabou rádio e
assim vem gente com a internet sem vem
com o youtube com plataformas que hoje
tem n plataformas de música você tem n
situações para ouvir notícias pra ver
notícias tv a cabo e tem tudo mas o
rádio continua firme e forte porque por
causa dessa emoção por causa dessa de
mexer com o imaginário porque o rádio é
o meio de estar mais conectado que
existe no nosso planeta
aí para a gente encerrar como eu falei
eu fui agora pouco
mas é uma homenagem que o prefeito rádio
né então rádio é realmente é essa esse
meio de conexão gente
o som rádio procurem sensações e emoções
o rádio pode ter certeza que vai ter é o
retorno de sair pra você vai mudar sua
vida em algum sentido se já não mudou de
alguns de vocês aqui o rádio
durante todo esse tempo então esse meio
fantástico vai continuar existindo por
muitos e muitos anos
e vocês vão sempre continuar ouvindo e
sentindo emoções e trabalhando e se
conectando estando junto com as pessoas
em todo mundo
obrigado gente por estarem aqui nessa
tarde gostosa brigada espero que eu
tenha sido bacana pra vocês valeu beijam
tchau